20 years that have cost so much
in time in money in lives and this week
veterans families asking what was it all
for
afghanistan back in the hands of the
taliban a decades-long mission ended in
chaos and crisis
parliament recalled to ask what went
wrong and how might the uk try to put
some of it right
the prime minister's view mission at
least partly accomplished the united
kingdom amongst others joined america in
going into afghanistan on a mission to
extirpate al-qaeda in that country and
to do whatever we could
to stabilize afghanistan in spite of all
the difficulties and challenges we knew
that we would face and we succeeded in
that core mission but in this chamber
packed for the first time in 17 months
the pm cuts a lonely figure detached
from the mood of his party just look at
the defense secretary
mps here see failure we are actually
seeding back the country to the very
insurgency that we went into defeat
in the first place and the reputation of
the west to support democracies across
the world has suffered will he now agree
to an independent formal inquiry into
the conduct in afghanistan
[Music]
mr speaker as i said in the house just a
few weeks ago there was an extensive uh
defense review about the afghan mission
after the combat mission ended in 2014
and i believe that uh most of the key
questions have already been extensively
gone into disbelief on his own back
benches there's clearly been a
catastrophic failure of our intelligence
or our assessment of the intelligence
because of the speed that this has
caught us unawares i think it'd be fair
to say that the events in afghanistan
have unfolded and the collapse has been
faster than i think even the taliban
themselves predicted what is not true is
to say that the uk government
was unprepared or did not foresee this a
surprise to mps at least
if this was foreseen how could it have
been allowed to come to pass
when it came for us to
look at the
the options
that this country might have
in view of the american decision
to withdraw
mr speaker we came up against this hard
reality the west could not continue
this u.s led mission without american
logistics without us air power and
without american might
but his predecessor damming of his
leadership or lack of it over
afghanistan
was our intelligence really so poor
was our understanding of the afghan
government so weak was our knowledge of
the position on the ground so inadequate
or did we really believe this
or did we just feel that we had to
follow the united states and hope that
on a wing and a prayer it would be all
right on the night what does it say
about us as a country what does it say
about nato we boast about global britain
but where is global britain on the
streets of kabul
a mission ending in failure and this
former pm clear who's to blame
all who served in afghanistan
should hold their heads high
and be proud
of what they achieved in that country
over 20 years the politicians sent them
there
the politicians decided to withdraw
the politicians must be responsible for
the consequences
the opposition agree labour say this
outcome could have been avoided there's
been a major miscalculation of the
resilience of the afghan forces
and staggering complacency from our
government about the taliban threat
the result
is that the taliban are backing control
of afghanistan
and we face new threats to our security
and an appalling humanitarian crisis the
most moving wars on afghanistan came
from a man who served there like many
veterans this last week has been one
that has seen me struggle
through anger and grief
and rage
because what we've done
in these last few days
is we've demonstrated that it's not
armies that win wars
armies can get tactical victories and
operational victories that can hold the
line
it's nations that make war
nations endure
and here we've demonstrated
sadly
that we
the west
the united kingdom
does not
this doesn't need to be defeat
but at the moment damn well feels like
it
davey
a ripple of applause revealing the deep
upset shared across this house mps
united in their sorrow their anger their
frustration about what's unfolded in
afghanistan the uk government says it
will take 20 000 afghan refugees over
the coming years but millions more are
living now in fear under taliban rule
mps believe we should have done we could
have done better but the prime minister
adamant that he was unwilling unable to
act without american leadership but
responsibility for this foreign policy
failure lies with him too this then a
watershed moment for boris johnson's
premiership and for global britain that
will reverberate for years to come
the pm said we have to face the hard
reality but that's now being felt not
here but in afghanistan and while we
have quit this war what happens next
will have consequences far beyond kabul